ein Fass ohne Boden ist auch die
corona-politik Impfstoffe maskentest all
das geht in die Milliarden aber die
schlimmste Kronach Folge ist für mich
persönlich der Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust
der Politik und anstatt diesen
aufzuarbeiten geht es auch schon wieder
los Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
verbreitet ungebrochene corona-panik
hören wir doch mal rein
ist jetzt wirklich an der Zeit die
Fallzahlen steigen die Zahl der
Todesfälle mit und an Corona steigt die
Intensivstationen
belegen sich zunehmend und sind in
einigen Bereichen bereits vor der
Überlastung wir haben darüber hinaus
keinen Grund anzunehmen dass die Welle
die wir jetzt vor uns haben dass sie
sich selbst
begrenzt das heißt es wird einfach immer
so weitergehen und die Frage ist
zumindest für die nächsten Wochen wird
es so weitergehen da wird es vielleicht
mal etwas langsamer steigen dann wieder
schneller steigen dann wieder etwas
langsamer steigen aber die Richtung in
die wir unterwegs sind ist keine gute
und wir wissen aus der Pandemie je
früher man die Bremse tritt
desto besser ist es weil wir müssen
lange auf der Bremse bleiben falls Sie
jetzt glauben dass es bestimmt ein
Einspieler der zwei Jahre her ist nein
das war erst vor wenigen Tagen in der
Bundespressekonferenz und ich frage mich
wirklich langsam was das eigentlich noch
soll also zum Beispiel Joe Biden der
amerikanische Präsident hat schon für
beendet erklärt aber Karl Lauterbach
macht immer weiter und damit nicht genug
erwirbt auch für das impfenumverdrossen
weiter 33 Millionen Euro kostet die
Impfkampagne ich schütze mich aber die
Wahrheit ist doch wer glaubt ihm denn
jetzt noch welche Impfung und wie viele
angebracht sind ich bin der Überzeugung
dass es allerhöchste Zeit für eine
ehrliche impfkommunikation ist denn das
Versprechen dass die corona-impfung
Schutz vor Ansteckung bietet ist nie
eingetreten laut der Zeitung Welt gab es
auch vor Zulassung nie Studien die
dieses Versprechen schützen schützen die
zwei g-regelung die hingegen wurde also
ohne jegliche Grundlage eingeführt und
ich bin der absenüberzeugung dass wir
mehr Glaubwürdigkeit in der Politik
brauchen ich habe hier heute Abend mit
Herr Rosen einen Kinderarzt sitzen und
da interessiert ich natürlich wie sie
das mit der Glaubwürdigkeit vor allem in
Bezug auf die Kinder sehen also vor
allem in Bezug auf die Kinder ist ja die
corona-pandemie von Anfang an nicht das
schreckensgespenst gewesen was es für
ältere Leute Erwachsene mit chronischen
Erkrankungen bietet insofern waren wir
als Kinderärzte da tatsächlich nicht an
der vordersten Front bei dieser Pandemie
Gott sei Dank muss man sagen ich sehe
das ein bisschen anders was die
Glaubwürdigkeit angeht ich glaube wir
haben es in dieser Pandemie oft die
Situation gesehen dass wir eine Art
trial error machen unsere Gesellschaft
hat zumindest in den letzten Jahrzehnten
mit so einer Herausforderung nicht zu
tun gehabt und wir waren das muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen auch als
Gesundheitswesen nicht darauf
vorbereitet und viele der Entscheidung
die getroffen wurden mögen im Nachhinein
als unzureichend falsch oder auch
verunsichernd wirken aber in der
Situation kann ich durchaus verstehen
dass sie getroffen wurden wir sind ganz
gut durch die panemie gekommen sehen uns
ein konkretes Beispiel nehmen wir mal
die 2g-regelung vom letzten Winter wo er
Menschen die hinfahren ausgeschlossen
wurden von der sozialen Teilhabe sehen
Sie das auch als Trial and Error was man
hinnehmen muss ich sehe es als Trial ob
man es hinnehmen
ganz klar sagen die corona-pandemie ist
ein globales Problem und wir hatten
keinen anderen Virus als die anderen
Länder das wurde bei uns nicht
eingeführt genau es gab Länder die noch
viel extremer als wir darauf reagiert
haben Spanien Italien China und es gab
Länder die weniger extrem reagiert haben
und jetzt im Nachhinein kann man sehen
manche Länder sind mit ihrem Kurs besser
gefahren als wir und andere nicht was
meinen Sie hier mit extremer weil von
der Länge der Maßnahmen her war zum
Beispiel Spanien nicht länger als
Deutschland in Spanien durften die
Kinder monatelang das Haus nicht
verlassen auch in Italien die Familien
waren eingesperrt da hatten wir noch
einen eine große Menge an Freiheiten ich
will gar nicht sagen dass alle Maßnahmen
richtig waren ich muss nur sagen als
jemand der im Gesundheitswesen arbeitet
der an der Impfkampagne beteiligt war
der täglich Aufklärungsgespräche geführt
hat mit Menschen mit Corona die Angst
hatten vor Corona die Angst hatten vor
der Impfung
das Problem der Glaubwürdigkeit kann ich
akzeptieren ich glaube aber das ist
insgesamt ein Problem war dass wir alle
in der Situation die Fakten nicht hatten
das kann man auch kritisieren warum
hatten wir die Fakten nicht warum wurde
nicht mehr investiert in bessere
Statistik und mehr Forschung zum
Beispiel dass man gemerkt hat dass man
sich nach der Impfung angesteckt hat
also da muss ich nur meinen
Freundeskreis gucken dass man nach der
zweiten Impfung sehr ersichtlich als
plötzlich der halbe Freundeskreis krank
war alle geimpft aber nicht schlimm das
muss man schon sagen also da scheint die
Impfung dann doch was gelindert zu haben
sie haben völlig recht man hat uns
versprochen einmal geimpft und du
brauchst keine Angst mehr haben das
Versprechen ist nicht angetreten aber
andererseits sind die schweren Verläufe
wie kein Mediziner die sind doch
deutlich zurückgegangen weil sich das
Virus verändert hat aber bei uns doch
das Immunsystem eine andere Form von
Resilienz hatte aber Virus hat sich auch
verändert und das Virus hat sich eben
auch verändert und das hat uns die
Impfung die Erfolge der Impfkampagne
hauptsächlich verhagelt wir haben gegen
einen Virus geimpft und plötzlich war
ein anderer Serotyp da und dann kam die
durchbruchinfekt das hat hätte man sehen
können dass das passieren kann aber die
Hoffnung war natürlich dass mit dieser
Impfung tatsächlich mehr Freiheiten
kommen die Realität sah tatsächlich
anders aus darf ich ihn mal ein ganz
konkretes Beispiel für meinen
Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust in die
Gesundheit also in den
Gesundheitsminister aber auch in die
Regierung aufzeigen die Empfehlungen für
die corona-impfung waren für meinen
60-Jährigen Vater und für mich als
30-jährige Frau damals noch 29 komplett
identisch das hat mich sehr gewundert
von Anfang an welchem Zeitpunkt
zweite Impfung das wurde uns dreien also
uns beiden komplett gleich empfohlen das
hatte ich mich damals sehr sehr stark
gewundert ob das nicht schon ein
Unterschied macht wie alt man ist wie
groß man ist also es gab ja gar keine
Differenzierung am Anfang in der
Impfkampagne sehe ich anders weil die
ständige Infusion hat natürlich die
alten Leute die Menschen über 60 das
kann man sagen 59 nicht aber die
Menschen über 60 priorisiert wir haben
ja alle warten müssen gut ich im
Gesundheitswesen nicht ich war in der
Notaufnahme damals tätig da habe ich als
allererste die Impfung bekommen aber
viele von meinen Bekannten in meinem
Alter
aber nicht von der Menge also die dritte
Booster Impfung zum Beispiel also ich
habe mich nicht wirklich abgeholt
gefühlt aber das hat mit dem Immunsystem
zu tun eine 2+1 Impfung ist ja das was
wir bei Tetanus und bei vielen anderen
Impfungen auch machen das Immunsystem
funktioniert einfach so dass man zwei
Erinnerungen braucht bei den meisten
Viren um anständig geschützt zu sein ich
kann ich kann sie total verstehen ich
glaube dass viele Leute
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem sehen ich will
oder argumentieren dass es nicht immer
nur schlechte Politik war sondern
sicherlich auch eine sehr
unübersichtliche und sich ständig
wandelnde Lage ich würde sagen das
größte Problem in der Kommunikation beim
Umgang mit der Pandemie war dass wir den
Eindruck erweckt hatten oder das einige
den Eindruck erweckt hatten Wissenschaft
könnte jetzt Politik ersetzen und das
kann sie eben nicht denn wir haben es
hier mit allen mit vielen Zielen zu tun
die Politik immer gegeneinander
ausbalancieren muss das können
ökonomische
Faktoren sein natürlich
gesundheitsfaktoren aber auch innerhalb
der Gesundheitsziele unterschiedliche
Ziele die gegeneinander stehen
psychologische Schäden die eintreten
wenn wir Menschen zu Hause lassen und
vieles mehr und es wurde immer der
Eindruck erweckt es gäbe den Königsweg
oder den richtigen Weg den gibt die
Wissenschaft vor und darüber werden
keine Debatte mehr möglich aber
unterschiedliche Ziele genau
gegeneinander abzuwägen und es gibt
keine Wissenschaft der Welt die der
Politik diese Aufgabe abnehmen kann mich
und das würde ich da knüpfig so ein
bisschen anders was du am Anfang glaube
ich gesagt hast Nina stört eigentlich
dass auch der Bundesgesundheitsminister
so tut als wenn wir uns wirklich so kann
man die Worte so ein bisschen deuten
noch ganz am Anfang dieser Pandemie
eigentlich befinden also wir sind
vielleicht im Sommer 2020 es gibt noch
keinen Impfstoff und wir wissen auch
noch gar nicht welche Masken wir
eigentlich tragen sollen und den
Eindruck hat man und wenn man in unsere
Gesellschaft reinhorcht ob es jetzt
Schulen sind ob es Behörden sind ob es
auch
Beschäftigte in verschiedenen Firmen
sind hat man doch häufig oder mein
Eindruck ist zumindest das ist eine neue
angstkultur gibt die eigentlich dort
aufhört wo wir im Frühjahr 2020 gewesen
sind also die so tut als wenn es die
ganzen Impfungen sie haben das ja gerade
auch gesagt nie gegeben hat sie haben
auch angesprochen dass man mit Impfungen
natürlich in der meisten Fällen gar
nicht so stark dann mehr erkrankte oder
die Symptome gar nicht so stark waren
und das macht ein riesen Unterschied für
die
Berechtigung für politische Eingriffe
gibt es jetzt noch fremdschutzaspekte
oder nicht genau und die Herausforderung
glaube die ist die ganz entscheidende
gerade auch mit Blick auf die Schulen
aus diesem angstmodus herauszukommen der
Bundesgesundheitsminister setzt sich hin
und sagt ja er spricht von Menschen die
mit und an Corona erkranken er weiß gar
nicht genau wie eigentlich die
Zusammensetzung ist sind es 90% mit
Corona und nur noch 10% an Corona oder
sind 95 zu fünf dass diese Zahlen liegen
der Bundesregierung
zumindestens gesagt das ist ja nur ein
Ausschnitt einer Presse gemacht sagt der
spielt gar keine Rolle
keine Rolle weil wenn derjenige dann
vielleicht nicht auch noch Corona
bekommen hätte trotz seiner Herzschwäche
wäre er nicht verstorben so erklärt
folgendem Grund spielt es in einem
Aspekt keine Rolle nämlich für den
Ausfall im Arbeitsmarkt ob jemand jetzt
wegen eines Verkehrsunfalls eine ins
Krankenhaus kommt und auf Corona positiv
getestet wird oder aufgrund einer
Atemwegsinfektion er wird positiver
Corona getestet und fällt für fünf bis
zehn Tage für den Arbeitsmarkt aus oder
die Schüler für den Schulen und das ist
eigentlich die große
furchtbarbefälle Sterbefall
wenn ich mit einem gebrochenen Bein
eingeliefert werde ins Krankenhaus und
zufällig festgestellt wird ich bin auch
noch an corona-erkrankt dann wäre ich
wegen des gebrochenen Beines ausgefallen
fünf Tage für die Arbeit aus weil
zusätzliches gebrochen
Zeigefinger was ich sagen will ist die
große Furcht ist dass diesen Winter
aufgrund von so vielen coronafällen wir
gesellschaftlich runterfahren müssen
weil keine Taxifahrer mehr da sind wir
mit den Corona Fällen anders
müsste neu diskutieren
zum Beispiel die Tumorerkrankungen es
wurden noch nie so schwere tumorfälle in
so einer Häufigkeit wie jetzt weil die
Menschen nicht mehr zu Vorsorge gegangen
sind riesen Problem
bei Kindern auch
permanent erzähle das schlimmste was
passieren kann ist eine
corona-erkrankung und so tut es der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ja auch noch
dann muss ich mich nicht wundern wenn
der Ruf als Echo zurückkommt und zwar in
folgender Gestalt das ganz ganz viele
Menschen panische Angst davor haben sich
wieder anzustecken und dann auch wenn
Sie den Coronavirus wieder haben oder
das erste Mal haben auch nicht zur
Arbeit gehen und und das Gefühl haben oh
Gott ich bin quasi Aussätziger ich muss
fünf bis zehn Tage zu Hause bleiben ob
ich Symptome habe oder nicht spielt
keine Rolle also der Umgang mit dem
Virus der ist eigentlich der gleiche wie
schon weiter diese panische Angst ist ja
nicht mehr da
die ist an Schulen sowas von verbreitet
die das ist das ist das glauben sie gar
nicht das ist da herrscht panische Angst
panische Angst davor da wird jetzt schon
darüber gerieben weiter zum Teil als der
Berliner Senat und der ist bei diesen
ganzen Ding immer schon ziemlich weit
gewesen